bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors pour commencer un
d'abord votre réaction à la découverte
des révélations de cette affaire dépend
de rappers
c'est un peu une réaction de dégoût
parce que
le dit pas assez mais ce scandale en
fait c'est un scandale après beaucoup
trop d'autres déjà il ya eu depuis une
quinzaine d'années lüthi plication ces
scandales et malheureusement ce qu'on se
rend compte à chaque fois c'est que
chaque nouveau scandale révèle que
l'ampleur de l'évasion fiscale ne cesse
d'augmenter et chaque nouveau scandale
révèle aussi que pendant ce temps là ça
s'est fait en toute impunité que les
pouvoirs publics n'ont pas pris les
décisions qu'il fallait pour mettre fin
à ce scandale et c'est vrai que là on a
un petit peu la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est que quand on voit des responsables
politiques de premier plan qui sont
mouillés dans ces scandales d'évasion
fiscale on peut douter effectivement de
leur volonté à mettre fin à ce scandale
quand eux-mêmes utilisent les paradis
fiscaux pour dissimuler d'en avoir et
bien quand on regarde leurs jolies
déclarations derrière pour dire on va
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale on peut
douter leur sincérité et c'est vrai que
tout cela montre bien que ce qui manque
en fait c'est une volonté politique de
mettre fin à cette évasion fiscale et
c'est pour ça que il faut que la
pression citoyenne se renforce et qu'on
multiplie par tous les actions les
différents types de mobilisation pour
forcer le dirigeant a en face attaquer à
ce problème qui n'est pas supportable en
fait nous sommes toutes et tous victimes
de l'évasion fiscale si vous n'avez pas
de place en crèche si vous avez vos
ensemble qui sont 36 dans une dans une
classe dans un collège ou un lycée c'est
notamment parce que cette évasion
fiscale nous prive de recettes et on
voit avec ce scandale qui encore une
fois est un nouveau scandale qui se
rajoute à plein d'autres que et bien ce
sont des sommes colossales qui manque
aux finances publiques et dans le même
temps on va demander aux gens de faire
des efforts on va par exemple dire il
faut réformer l'allocation chômage et ça
va pénaliser à 2015 millions de chômeurs
et dans le même temps ne fait rien pour
aller chercher l'argent là où il est
c'est à dire dans les paradis fiscaux
alors vous parliez de pression citoyenne
longue de chacun de ces révélations a
entraîné la démission du premier
ministre islandais du chef du
gouvernement pakistanais
vous pensez que cette enquête pourrait
mener
selon vous à des poursuites devant les
tribunaux des pays concernés est ce que
c'est possible ça risque peut-être
d'être compliqué pour le roi abdallah ii
de jordanie mais quand même c'est
possible
ça se fait souhaitable mais on le voit
aussi effectivement vous venez de le rap
et puis les parents que le premier
ministre islandais c'est au moment des
panamas peppers si je me souviens bien
on voit que la justice fiscale crée un
sentiment de plus en plus de colère chez
les citoyens et qu' il est possible
effectivement de chasser nos dirigeants
corrompus par la rue alors après il y
serait souhaitable aussi que ces
délinquants en col blanc soient traités
comme des délinquants si vous volez une
pomme pour manger et bien vous allez
rendre des comptes à la justice et on se
rend compte que ces délinquants en col
blanc dont les l'évasion fiscale
représente des sommes bien plus
importante et chaque trop souvent à la
justice donc nous on demande
effectivement un renforcement des moyens
humains matériels techniques pour
pouvoir poursuivre ces personnes et est
par exemple on vous propose un truc qui
est tout bête mais d'arrêter de
supprimer des postes de contrôle fiscal
est au contraire d'augmenter les moyens
d' administration fiscale on a un
gouvernement français qui prétend lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale et qui depuis
cinq ans n'a fait que supprimer des
postes de l'administration fiscale et
vous fermer des centres de finances
publiques ou va bien effectivement qu'on
peut pas prétendre lutter contre ce
problème si en même temps on enlève des
moyens aux administrations qui luttent
contre ce problème donc il faut
effectivement une réponse
l'administration fiscale il faut une
dépense judiciaire faire en sorte que
ces délinquants en col blanc cesse de
jouir de l'impunité dont il bénéficie
alors les chiffres de l'évasion fiscale
en font tourner les têtes en france on
parle de 100 milliards peut être plus
qui échapperaient chaque année au fisc
est ce qu'il existe selon vous un moyen
efficace de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale qui est donc une nouvelle fois
mis en lumière par les pandora peppers
mais il y en a plein depuis 20 ans pour
les réclames et puis d'autres
organisations les réclames le problème
c'est le monde des politiques alors il
ya plusieurs choses à faire déjà il faut
imposer la transparence fiscale ça passe
notamment par ce qu'on appelle leur
porting public pays par pays des
entreprises multinationales ou ça passe
aussi pour les particuliers par toute la
transparence autour des sociétés croit
on voit bien que là en fait cette
enquête a permis de révéler que derrière
des caches l'on en fait ce prêt de se
cacher de des personnes qui n'étaient
pas des vrais détenteurs sur le papier
de ses avoirs et donc on a un vrai
problème aujourd'hui de manque de
transparence fiscale on peut aussi
réformer la fiscalité internationale on
a une proposition qui est qui est très
simple qui s'appelle la taxation
unitaire des multinationales arrêter de
faire semblant que ce sont des filiales
séparées les unes des autres et arrêter
de croire par exemple qu amazon ne
réalise pas de bénéfices en europe ce
qui lui paraît le payer zéro euro
d'impôt de la société ce qui est
totalement aberrant pour conseiller les
ventes record qu'elle réalise depuis
c'est pareil pour beaucoup d'autres
multinationales donc là il s'agirait la
taxation unitaire de les considérer
comme un tout déterminé grâce à la
transparence fiscale quelles sont leurs
activités réelles dans chaque pays et de
les taxer proportionnellement à leurs
activités dans chaque pays ce que révèle
ce scandale c'est bien le manque de
volonté politique c'est par un problème
de manque de solutions techniques c'est
un problème de manque de volonté
politique et c'est pour ça j'encourage
les personnes qui nous regardent à se
mobiliser pour faire en sorte de crier
notre notre colère face à l'injustice
fiscale et faire en sorte que enfin ça
s'arrête on n'est pas besoin d'abord
encore trois ou quatre nouveaux
scandales d'évasion fiscale pour
qu'enfin les responsables politiques se
mettent à aller à mettre fin à ce
problème
raphaël prado merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le porte parole d'attac france